قالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه
ماريا زخرفه ان استخدام السلاح النووي من
قبل روسيا ممكن فقط لاغراض دفاعيه واضافت
في مؤتمر صحفي انضمام اوكرانيا الى حلف
شمال الاطلسي او تطبيق ما يعرف بالنموذج
الاسرائيلي للتعاون بين الجانبين لا يمكن
ان يساعد في تسويه الوضع في اوكرانيا وان
تسويه الازمه في اوكرانيا سيكون بعودتها
الى ما وصفتها بوضعيه الحياد
فيما يخص ما تبقى من الدوله الاوكرانيه
بعد التجارب الغربيه عليها فانما يضمن
امنها هو عودتها الى وضع الحياد خارج
الحلف وتاكيد وضعها الغير النووي ولحل
الازمه الاوكرانيه من الضروري الاعتراف
بالمناطق الجديده وفق الحقائق الراهنه
وضمان كييف للحقوق الاساسيه لمواطنيها
والسكان الناطقين باللغه الروسيه وممثلي
الاقليات بما في ذلك
منح اللغه الروسيه وضعا رسميا ووقف
الاعمال القتاليه وعلى الدول الغربيه وقف
مد كييف بالاسلحه